special effects artists and prop
designers play a
huge role in creating movie magic they
find creative ways to ensure that props
look
as realistic as possible to find out how
these props are created
let's take a look at what 9 looked like
behind the scenes
prop glass is extremely fun to break and
is completely safe
this fake glass is made out of a corn
syrup mixture and
is sometimes referred to as candy glass
the glass can be molded into beer
bottles or flat panes
and the final product is brittle and
breaks easily and
safely however this fake glass would
still be uncomfortable to walk on
barefoot
like bruce willis had to do in die hard
so for scenes like that
glass shards made of rubber are used
instead
because there are strict rules for
having real babies on set
fake babies are sometimes used instead
in movies and tv shows
the babies are created by pouring
silicone into a mold
silicone is used because it has the same
slightly translucent quality as human
skin
after drying the babies are painted with
several different types of paint to make
their skin look like it's flush with
blood
then each hair on the baby's head is
added one at a time
it takes about three weeks to complete
just one fake baby
regular food could melt or go bad under
the hot lights of a movie set
over time so movie producers will often
have a prop designer create
fake foods for movies instead and they
get creative with materials
like using caulking for cake frosting or
corkboard for ground beef
to make most food items they first
create a mold based on the real food
and fill it with rubber or foam after
the prop has dried it's sanded down and
painted with details to look more
realistic
on certain occasions real food is simply
covered in resin to help preserve it
fake vomit comes in all different shapes
sizes and textures
it can be realistic or exaggerated
depending on the genre
creating fake vomit starts by mixing
together different types of foods
for a more traditional vomit they
combine top ramen
and tomato paste
actors will put some of this mixture
into their mouths before the beginning
of the shot
before spitting it out on cue but to
create a more dramatic vomit scene
the fake vomit is shot out of a tube
the thicker part of this food mixture is
loaded into one end
the watery part is pumped into the tube
as well
pushing out the solids and creating a
vomit explosion
to create more exaggerated vomiting
small holes can be added to the end of
the tubing to produce a larger spray
sometimes these tubes are removed in
post-production
while other times it's all about picking
the right camera angle
the blood sugar levels of this fake
blood is through the roof
since fake blood is almost entirely
composed of corn syrup
the only other ingredients are an o
pacifier to make the blood cloudier
and food coloring a little bit of blue
food coloring is added to the red to
darken it and add complexity to the
mixture
the fake blood can then be shot out of a
cannon if you need to simulate a
headshot
or sprayed if the fake wound is the
result of a slash
rubber blood can also be used when
filming needs to be stain free
the easiest way to create a fake burn
wound is with
a simple temporary tattoo they stay on
all day
and they're easy to apply but they're
not the most realistic
so for more complicated burn wounds
makeup artists will typically use
glutzen bald cap plastic this plastic
can either be painted
or burned to give it a singed appearance
the bald cap plastic is then applied to
the skin with an adhesive
and the edges are painted to blend in
for larger burn areas
sheets of silicone can be used the
silicone is molded
painted and then applied directly onto
the actor
fake body parts are a necessary prop for
many tv shows and movies
especially those that involve gore
these fake bodies are typically created
by filling molds with polyphone
sometimes an actor will have to go
through a life casting
which creates a perfect mold of their
facial features
the polyfoam body parts are then layered
with paint
the expert painters can replicate all
manner of injuries
from shotgun wounds to frostbite
whether you need a snow storm a huge
gust of wind or a rain shower
practical effects artists have you
covered because you can't always count
on the weather
movies and tv shows often need to come
up with other ways to create
fake weather for a scene giant fans are
used for wind
and piping rigs can produce realistic
raindrops
to emulate light snow small pieces of
paper mache or plastic are blown through
this machine
sometimes a special soap-based foam is
used instead
which doesn't stain or make the ground
slippery
the hairs on fake beards and wigs are
often threaded by hand
one at a time this means that making a
fake beard can sometimes take
up to six days to create these pieces
hairs are either punched into a
prosthesis one at a time
or are individually woven into a lace
foundation
however if time is of the essence fake
hair can also be applied directly to an
actor's face with glue
not only do hair artists need to
consider how they're going to apply hair
to an after
but also what kind of hair they're going
to use rough yak hair
is good for beards and finer angora hair
is used for eyebrows
what are some of your favorite movie
props and practical effects
let us know in the comments